à deux pas de la forêt de rambouillet
dans le village de la celle les bordes
se cache ce château privé propriété de
thierry gaubert
classé monument historique il a été
construit entre 1671 1614 à l'époque
d'henri iv
celui qui a construit le château a été
héritée de la famille art ville qui
possédait un château ici à 2km château
du moyen âge et au lieu de moderniser le
château de le reconstruire
ils ont repensé à châteauneuf depuis 17
ans et irrigue aube et sa famille qui
s'en occupent cinq hectares de propriété
et une collection plutôt atypique
plus de 2000 bois de cerf il s'agit de
la première collection de france voire
d'europe disent certains un héritage du
temps de la duchesse d'uzès propriétaire
des lieux en 1870 qui en a fait son
centre de chasse à courre la collection
de boîtes faire date de 1870 là parce
qu'il y avait ce que les serbes viennent
tous d'affairé dans boys ont tous été
châtié à court en faisant bien c'est pas
une collection qui vient du monde entier
et elle date de le commensal 870 c'est
la collection in situ se terminer dans
les années 50
mobilier d'époque tapisserie ou encore
objets rares thierry gaubert a ajouté sa
patte ce château collectionneur d'art
historien il a rénové en gardons
l'esprit 17e on se doit de respecter moi
je dis toujours
ne détruisez pas ce que vous n'aimez pas
mais fait ailleurs voyez on aura des
très beaux bâtiments race des choses
magnifiques beaucoup trop si ça vous
plait pas fait ailleurs mais ne
détruisez pas ce qui a été fait par les
anciens et jeudi détruire une oeuvre
ancienne s'est tué une deuxième fois
celui qui l'a construite il est possible
de visiter le château sur réservation et
pour un groupe de 20 personnes minimum
l'entrée est à 10 euros